Superhero movies might be the biggest thing
at the box office today, and with the kind
of epic action that we’re getting from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe, it’s easy to
see why. That hasn’t always been the case,
though. The history of the genre is full of
catastrophic failures that never managed to
save the day for audiences or critics. From
obscure heroes who were a little too bizarre
to household names that had a rough road to
the screen, here are the worst superhero movies
ever made.
Barb Wire
Barb Wire might not be a traditional superhero,
but with her over-the-top costume, dystopian
sci-fi setting, and roots on the page, she
seemed like the perfect comic book character
to make Pamela Anderson an action star…
in theory. In practice, the 1996 adaptation
didn’t give the fans or the cast anything
they wanted, except maybe seeing Anderson
in a leather costume that the Telegraph called
"unnecessarily revealing."
Set in the distant future of 2017, the movie
starred Anderson as Barb Wire, a bartender
and bounty hunter trying to escape the Second
American Civil War by dealing with a mobster
named Big Fatso and making enough money to
move to Canada. With a premise like that,
it’s easy to see why Anderson thought she
was signing on for what she called "a dark
comedy," about a blonde, big-haired badass
riding around on a motorcycle. With the studio
demanding changes to the script, a new director,
and less humor, however, what could've been
a campy classic was tanked from the start.
Howard the Duck
You might've been excited to see Howard the
Duck pop up in the post-credits scene in Guardians
of the Galaxy, but don’t let your interest
in one of Marvel’s more obscure characters
trick you into watching his first feature
film outing from 1986. Produced by George
Lucas — yes, that George Lucas — the movie
starred Back to the Future’s Lea Thompson,
giving it a sci-fi pedigree that any movie
in the '80s would've been jealous of. Unfortunately,
while Universal was trying to get the guy
who made Star Wars, they got the guy who made
The Phantom Menace instead.
“What I don’t know is what the hell I’m
doing here.”
After Robin Williams wisely passed on the
role, the job of voicing Howard went to theater
actor Chip Zien, who knew something was wrong
when he had to buy his own ticket to see the
movie he starred in. As he later said in an
interview, by the time they’d gotten through
111 minutes of a duck puppet’s questionable
romance with Marty McFly’s mom, he and his
friend Roy were alone in the theater. Everyone
else had bailed.
“Howard you really are the worst.”
Green Lantern
With roles in Blade Trinity and Deadpool,
Ryan Reynolds has had decent luck with superhero
movies. His attempt at bringing DC’s Green
Lantern to life in 2011, however, risked ruining
his career and taking the whole superhero
genre with it. After it cost a whopping $300
million to make — about 80 million more
than it took in — the scathing reviews and
terrible box office numbers threatened to
turn studios off the idea of comic book movies
altogether.
Fortunately for Reynolds and the entire superhero
genre, the same weekend Green Lantern opened,
he shot the now-famous Deadpool test footage
that would convince Fox to give him a shot
at redemption. Reynolds took the chance, and
unlike Green Lantern, Deadpool was an R-Rated
smash
Steel
Black Panther brought superheroics to Africa
and moviegoers into theaters in record-breaking
numbers, and Blade kicked off the modern superhero
film, but neither King T'Challa nor the Daywalker
were the first black comic book hero to make
it to the big screen. It’s often overlooked,
but Shaquille O'Neal beat them both to the
punch when he starred in the 1997 adaptation
of DC's Steel… although you can’t really
blame anyone for forgetting about this downright
awful movie. It was so bad that director Kenneth
Johnson apologized for it, admitting that
he probably should have walked away once he
found out who his star was going to be.
Shaq definitely had the heroic proportions
to bring the Superman-inspired armored hero
to life, but lacked the acting chops to save
a miserable script that feels like a bad first
draft of Iron Man. As Johnson revealed, however,
Warner Bros. co-president Bill Gerber opted
for O'Neal over the likes of Wesley Snipes
and Denzel Washington because he thought Shaq
would "sell more toys." Considering Gerber
was fired the next year, we’re guessing
the toy sales weren't much better than the
movie.
Spawn
When you sit down to watch a DVD commentary
and the first thing the director says is "you
can blame it all on me," that’s not a good
sign. That's exactly how Mark Dippè introduces
himself in the Spawn commentary. At the time,
he was known as a visual effects wizard, but
he'd never directed a movie before — and
it showed. When Den of Geek revisited the
1997 film, they pointed out that for a movie
based entirely around its visuals, quote,
“a good number of the effects aren't good.
Some are flat out awful."
As a former staffer at Industrial Light and
Magic, the visual effects should’ve been
Dippè’s specialty, although as far as he
was concerned, the CGI wasn't the problem.
Speaking to Wired in 1997, the outspoken filmmaker
lashed out at censors, claiming,
"The MPAA is driving a stake through my heart
with this, because they're making me take
this movie down so much."
He also called it "a very positive story,"
which is a little hard to believe considering
that it’s a movie about a zombie superhero
getting yelled at by a demon clown.
Daredevil
Long before he donned the Dark Knight's cape
and cowl in the DC film universe, Ben Affleck
made his ill-fated foray into the superhero
genre with 2003's Daredevil. Despite Affleck’s
genuine love for the character, the cinematic
version suffered from the tonal whiplash of
ultra-serious images mixed with goofy action
like the playground fight between Daredevil
and Elektra, and a murderous supervillain
whose menacing insanity came off as cartoonish
— and not in the good way.
With a bad script and incredibly awkward visual
effects, it’s no surprise that critics offered
up some unfavorable comparisons to Spider-Man,
which hit theaters the previous year. They
weren’t the only ones. Affleck himself called
Daredevil the only movie that he regrets making,
and agreed that the 2015 Netflix version was
doing the character far better than a movie
that, as he said, quote, "never kind of got
it right."
The Fantastic Four
Technically, Roger Corman's The Fantastic
Four has never been released, but this low-budget
take on Marvel's first family became a thing
of legend after bootleg copies began making
their way around the convention circuit. The
story goes that Neue Constantin Films contacted
the veteran B-movie producer after failing
to secure a $40 million partnership with 20th
Century Fox. Nobody else wanted in, so since
the rights to the Marvel property would expire
if a movie wasn’t in production by December
31, 1992, Corman was hired to make the cheapest
movie he could.
“God help us!”
The result was a movie so legendarily bad
that it became the subject of a 2015 documentary
called Doomed from director Marty Langford.
The saddest revelation in that film was that
the cast had no idea that they were just making
a movie to help secure the rights, and that
there were never any plans to actually release
it and give a cast of unknowns their big breaks.
“Look at it! See it! Does it amuse you?”
You can’t blame them for being fooled, but
they probably should’ve noticed something
was up when they could barely hear Dr. Doom’s
dialogue over the clanking of his armor, or,
you know, when they saw what the Thing was
supposed to look like. To be fair, though,
the origin story in this film is actually
more faithful to the comics than in any other
Fantastic Four movie to date. Of course, the
fact that we still think this one is the worst,
even after those other three, should give
you an idea of just how bad it is.
Catwoman
If you watch Halle Berry's notoriously terrible
Catwoman movie and Christopher Nolan's game-changer
Batman Begins back to back, it's hard to believe
there was only a single year between them.
This extremely loose DC adaptation was nominated
in seven categories at the Razzies and triumphed,
sort of, in four, including Worst Actress
for Berry. She even showed up in person to
collect the award along with co-star Alex
Borstein and her Academy Award, and started
off by thanking the studio for casting her
in what she called “a godawful movie.”
And that was the nicest thing she said about
it in that speech.
Rest assured, it actually is that bad. In
addition to scenes where Berry’s magical
cat powers kick in during a basketball game
and cause her to swat at the ball like a ball
of yarn, it’s full of cringeworthy stereotypes
for a female superhero. Seriously: Catwoman
fights a villain whose big plan is to distribute
evil makeup, because she’s mad that she’s
starting to look old.
In 2018, Berry addressed Catwoman once again
while accepting the Matrix Award from New
York Women in Communication. She acknowledged
how bad the picture was, but she defended
her decision to accept the role, revealing
that the, quote, "sh--load of money" she made
changed her life and that the movie taught
her “what not to do.”
Captain America
After ten years of the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
it's hard to imagine anyone but Chris Evans
as Captain America. Back in 1990, though,
Matt Salinger, son of famed American author
J. D. Salinger — was tossing shields when
Evans was still in elementary school. Originally
intended to be released on the 50th anniversary
of Captain America’s first appearance, this
low-budget Marvel adaptation was never actually
finished, with the production running aground
before the final scenes were shot. Unwilling
to send the existing footage to the deep,
dark vault that it most certainly belonged
in, studio execs had editors cobble together
a version that could be released on VHS.
“Mr. President! Thanks!”
Salinger later revealed that the film was
as grueling to shoot as it is to watch, with
his rubber suit causing him to overheat. On
top of that, the costume looked ridiculous,
thanks largely to the addition of rubber ears
attached to the helmet, and the movie’s
Red Skull was inexplicably portrayed as an
Italian mobster, complete with a hilariously
over the top accent.
“That was a gun … THIS is a detonator.
Did you really expect me to be taken alive?!”
As for the script, well, there’s a scene
where Cap grabs the Red Skull by the wrist
and the Skull pulls out a knife... and chops
off his own hand. Not exactly the evil mastermind
fans were expecting.
Condorman
Dubbed an "ideological intervention from the
Disney machine" by Time Out, 1981's Condorman
is a camp cocktail of Cold War spy thriller,
comedy and superhero movie, all watered down
for family consumption. This misfire from
the Mouse House stars Michael Crawford as
Woody Wilkins, a comic book creator who insists
on doing everything he writes in real life,
just to prove it can be done. After accidentally
getting involved with a seductive Soviet spy,
Wilkins has to become the hero he created,
flying and all.
For the most part, Crawford himself was in
the ghastly Condorman suit — and at one
point, he almost died in it. After falling
into a river in costume, the gigantic wings
dragged him down and nearly drowned him, making
the film unpleasant on both sides of the camera.
That said, it’s been more than 35 years
since Condorman hit theaters. Maybe it’s
time to introduce Disney’s first attempt
at a superhero to the MCU… or not.